president Felix chisaki arrived at a
parked stadium in kinasa he's running
for a second time in office in his first
campaign rally ahead of the general
election in December the Congo Le
president told voters that he wants to
complete what he started 5 years ago
when he took office we have two choices
before us the first is to choose to go
back to zero give the future we've paid
for to people who will bring us into
madness or we can choose the second
choice consolidate the gains that we
have and will continue to
achieve Mo Kumi another presidential
candidate launched his campaigns in
kangani in the
Northeast he's a former governor of the
mineral Rich region of katanga he says
the president has not delivered on
promises he made including dealing with
fighting in the East corruption and poor
governance I know you are suffering so
so much here I have seen myself even as
I came today no roads no electricity
this must end we will bring change as we
will take office we don't need fake
promises again Martin fulu came second
in the last poll he disputed the results
saying it was wed he believes he's the
man to bit if the election is free and
fair there are displaced people that
have left the places where the congales
being killed and today there's no one to
take care of them there's no government
some congales are worried that the
Electoral commission may not be prepared
to deliver a credible poll because of a
lack of transparency in the process
Catherine so Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz